have you ever felt lonely the urge of
wanting to connect with people but you
seem to have no one you really would
want to contact or it's a Friday night
and you want to be with others but you
have no energy to go out so instead you
sit at home all evening watch Netflix
and feel more alone than ever you feel
like a monster between humans that know
how to function this is what loneliness
felt like to me so I'm an artist and I
process my emotional world by sharing my
feelings for my art if you share your
feelings with someone and they
understand and share those feelings to
you create an emotional and deep
connection this is why you can be
surrounded by hundreds of people jump
from one thing a day to the next but
still feel lonely it's because these
deeper connections haven't been made so
I was an always happy child I think we
nearly have no single photo of me where
I don't smile broadly or laugh or joke
around and this went on until well it's
tells a case but I had many friends
group up until as a young adult I moved
to another city for my first job as a
comic artist and like so many young
thriving people all over the planet I
concentrated all my energy into my work
life but if you spend like 90 percent of
your daily capacity trying to succeed at
work of course there's nothing left to
take care of all the other important
aspects in your life like your human
relationships nourishing friendships
as an adult it's work you need to be
consistent with connecting you need to
be open you need to be honest
and this is all I struggled with because
I tend to come and flash my real
feelings by trying to appear always
happy and trying to make everyone else
happy too by trying to fix their
problems and I know a lot of us are
guilty of this because it's an easy way
to not think about your own issues isn't
it
[Laughter]
the turning point came when I fell into
an emotionally abusive relationship just
a few years ago he isolated me and left
me feeling more alone than ever it was
the lowest point in my life but it was
also my wake-up call because it was the
first time that I really felt like
loneliness many artists put their
feelings into the art there are endless
books movies paintings musics all filled
with a real emotion of an artist so as
an artist myself I did the same
I shared my feelings I wanted to help
people cope with loneliness I wanted ya
to make some understand that to really
experience it through my art in a form
of an interactive story a video game so
in our game we called it sea of solitude
you are a person named Kay who is
suffering from such strong loneliness
that her inner feeling the anger feeling
of hopelessness worthlessness turned to
the outside and she becomes a monster
the game well Kay is actually a
representation of me and the past I went
through to overcome my struggles
the game plays actually in case mine so
you walk through a word that is flooded
by her tears and the weather changing by
her mood how the mood is changing of her
and well the only thing he wears the
only thing is her backpack
it's a baggage we all carry throughout
our life and Kay doesn't know how to
cope with her emotions in the right way
so her backpack becomes bigger and
bigger until it bursts and she finally
is forced to overcome her own struggles
so in our story we present many
different manifestations of loneliness
loneliness through social exclusion is
very common in our game the brazza of k
get bullied in his school and he just
wants to hide and fly away and we
portray him as a huge bird monster
surrounded by thick fog the player has
to actually walk through his school and
experience the really feels harm that
the brother had been through because for
a long time nobody really listens to him
but the very moments like friends and
family start to listen the first step
towards overcoming this form of
loneliness had been made we also show
loneliness and relationships like when
parents just stay together for the sake
of the kids but end up hurting the
entire family we put the player
literally in between the two parents
while they are fighting and you get hurt
in the middle they don't even see that
their daughter K is right there until
she breaks down we also show loneliness
through mental health issues where's the
boyfriend of Kay who suffers from
depression and shows that sometimes it
is most important to focus on your own
way
being first the boyfriend also tends to
camouflage his feelings so he appears
like a long shiny white wolf but the
moment he starts and to interact with
his girlfriend Kay the mask falls off
and we see the black dog beneath it
depression sometimes we put on a smile
instead of dealing with the issues at
hand and that can ultimately make it
worse affect the people around us and
damage our relationships
it's okay yourself we portray as ripped
apart into her basic emotions some help
you some trying to stop you self-doubt
is a huge creature always telling Kay
how worthless she is and that she should
just give up like in real life
self-doubt is blocking the path and it
seems impossible to overcome it
destroying the only presents of
self-doubt is a slow process but in the
game like it slowly like shrink hers so
she turns from self-doubt to actually
healthy doubt and you can finally trust
her advice we also show self-destruction
it's a huge monster always lurking
nearby and as a water surface
self-destruction is actually the main
antagonist of the game and she is always
trying to drown you in the ocean of
Tears but when she actually drowns you
you wake up just a few moments ago and
you have a chance to progress again we
wanted to show that we all go through
hardships in our life we all but if you
at least like stand up and try to move
forward you are very likely to make it
through your struggles like step by step
joy
enjoy something that K cannot really
embrace or touch it's always something
in the distance we've hurt rape joy as a
child version of K like with a yellow
raincoat so she is invertible to the
ocean of tears but joy can also turn
into obsession and start to be actually
harmful for k like when she start
obsessing over her boyfriend joy will
not turn back to normal antic he is
realizing that her happiness should not
depend on anybody else but herself
so our monsters appear you turn scary
but if you overcome your reluctance and
approach them you soon see that they are
no monsters at all but just fragile
beings that are simply overwhelmed by
what life throws at them all of those
emotions be it saved out or even safe
distraction don't completely vanish in
our game the key message is to not only
chase for joy or happiness but to
embrace all your emotions and bringing
them into balance being okay with
sometimes not being okay so everyone had
its own loneliness story to tell the
serialization changed everything for me
like being much more open with my
emotions and concentrating much more on
to my private life my friends my family
when we released the game like literally
thousands of fans wrote us all sharing
the stories with us and telling us said
they felt not so alone anymore just
because he played our game now many
people brought assets they felt hope for
a better future for themself for the
first time indicates many broad asset
they seek therapy now just because
active help yeah just because he
our game and fell hopeful to overcome
their own struggles our game is not a
therapy it's not meant to be a therapy
it's just my friends and me sharing our
stories through our video games but we
are so deeply thankful for every single
message that people feel better just
because we shared our story with them so
I I don't completely overcame my urge to
help others but I don't want to overcome
it anymore I love it I just needed to
bring it to a healthy size so it doesn't
stand in the way of deeper relationships
anymore but even helped me to connect
with people so if you have an inner
monster that is born out of negative
emotions it is not only the goal to kill
that monster but to understand that we
humans are complex beings look at what
part of your life is so big that others
fall short look at what emotion you
barely feel or maybe feel too much and
move towards lowering those Peaks most
of all it's about understanding that all
the wide range of emotions and struggles
makes us what we are humans thank you
[Applause]